one activity that helps people warm up
in the diverge stage is the Crazy Eights
you give everyone a sheet of paper and
you ask them to fold it three times to
create eight different rectangles then
in each rectangle you put one idea
related to the product now you only have
five minutes to do this activity so you
go as quickly as possible and you try
and push yourself to put something in
every single box no this activity can be
a little bit intimidating to people who
aren't designers so here are a few tips
for what you can do first it's a good
idea to remind yourself and the team
about common UI elements most UI
components are very basic shapes like
rectangles and circles and they can be
drawn pretty easily you might remind
your team of some of those shapes like
lists and icons and buttons and titles
you might also just spend a few minutes
looking at mobile patterns so that way
you can check out what others have done
you might also download free mobile or
web UI kits so that way you can go
through some of those design components
just be sure not to leave these
resources up during an activity because
the focus should be on sketching ideas
all right now it's your turn
set a timer for five minutes and sketch
eight ideas that you have that are
related to the super duper shopping app
now keep in mind the activity that you
did with the Golden Path and remember
that main user journey or that story
that you created once you've completed
this activity check this box to continue